welcome to this video playing hogaf
okay from Spain I really don't remember
what this guy is playing with black yeah
he's playing beef three all the time
which I clearly remember of course
I'm still having a fantastic score yeah
14 out of 17.
that's neat ah I actually forgot to play
Knight F3 which I wanted on move 5 but
okay let's see
aha well that's it that's quite
quite uncommon is this type of approach
that he's playing giving up the the
Bishops with and then not trying to open
up the position quickly he's setting up
a stone wall instead
aha okay
so how am I playing that he's
um yeah he's trying to to do something
on the light squares
I probably should regroup to D3 maybe A4
is a threat hmm
maybe I should have started with B3 yeah
now
okay
um just I just saw it right after I
allowed the thing
so sometimes a bit awkward to have the
pawns fixed here on on dark squares
nothing
um super terrible but um
something that I would have liked to
avoid
okay
yeah that's not good
not good
Bishop F4 this even G5 Maybe
I can go Bishop D6 then it's not clear
to me but I don't want to to play
Passive stuff
now G5 Bishop D6 is probably alright
so he's not going for that at all but
rather opens up here
voice is hanging as well
E3 is really not what I want to do
yeah
this was really bad yeah to allow A4 was
a bad idea
still surprised that he's
I'm still surprised about how he's
playing this
C5 immediately hmm
Maybe
okay something like B4
takes Queen takes this Knight D2
that's not great
let me prepare that that also intends
Bishop to D6
maybe bishop D6 Queen takes Queen C4
G5 Bishop D6 can take well G5 cool what
the what a silly move okay
um this moves okay
look B1 probably
yeah just this one
trying to open it up with B3 or B4
something like that
yeah not not great all this is not great
B3 he will take it not good B4 he will
take A3 also not good
okay
can I do Rook D4
making sure that
I guess I can
always E5 even possible
well it's not that's not a big problem
now E5 I can take on
C4 with the bishop
okay if I take now we have a
simplification
I don't know yeah come on I need to I
want to simplify matters a bit
of course he has this long diagonal but
I'm getting there as well on my own long
diagonal
so let's let's start with this Rook D6
coming
Rook D6 or something else
hmm
or queen C3 Alex let's try to get get on
those squares
Bishop here Queen F7 hmm
I know let's let's block it Bishop F3
there's Rook D7
this should be quite helpful this Rook
D7 idea
Queen E5 now so that after Bishop takes
I can take E6
trying to defend actively here not
passively
E4 maybe do I get in there no let's
let's
detecting three for the moment I'm not
protecting it what am I doing here
you can just take it
ah no
what the heck
oh great a great level of concentration
that I'm displaying here
um unbelievable
and I want the bishop on C3 trying to
activate them
you can maybe even play Queen B3
trying to end them
yeah
wow what did I do to my position it
wasn't even that bad
I just I just blundered blundered the
whole thing there
check
where's his check now
check on F1 Maybe
let's just take this
take this first
yeah I want seven seconds yeah
he has totally spoiled it to to nothing
and I have second seconds seven seconds
of course I deserve a loss from my my
bad bad play earlier
but um
position is totally equal
I can resign I have two seconds yeah but
check
check white forfeits on time yeah I'm
sometimes really ridiculous I was just
blundering this bloody Pawn Yeah
in a position where I really shouldn't
lose anymore
let's let's check there I mean I can't
go Queen C7 of course which is simple
I mean this is never never that bad for
me I don't really believe it
yeah Queen C7 is simply I I simply I
simply blundered this thing
and here
here I'm awesome I'm simply worse
he also has this this kind of idea Queen
takes Rook C8
of course I made a number of mistakes
earlier especially especially uh
allowing A4 so it's really bad I mean
I really must prevent that I mean
like B3 or something
to be perfectly Frank there's this whole
black setup is totally anti-positional
giving up the dark squared bishop and
then setting up a stone wall
but um I I really played this Knight E1
is a normal maneuver but I I played it
far too quickly allowing this stuff
after that Lucas has gained quite a lot
because he gets control over C4
which was unnecessary I need to play
that which is much better
without a dark squared Bishop he is
simply suffering forever here I'm going
to go Bishop F4
and I have excellent control over the
dark squares also this Maneuvers is part
of the of the whole
the whole procedure but I was just
playing this far too quickly this um
allowing a form and after that black was
was totally okay
even with some strange moves like C5 I
mean I found it strange
why not just Bishop A6 first and stuff
like that but okay it was probably okay
to play anyway
and Bishop B5 was me but I don't know I
mean around here I'm at least equal
but um I totally screwed it up
afterwards
Rook D6 is probably better
no I don't know mostly I just just
Blended blended it all away with F3
giving away F3 wow okay thanks for
watching